Jermaine's house is right on the edge of
Rolling Fork it was the first to be hit
when a tornado destroyed this town
his wife Chandra is trying to retrieve
money they've been saving for years from
the wreckage
it's coming in fairs so we're looking at
seeing that they're doing like that just
integrated
he was pinned under this tire as the
wind sent his car flying overhead what
have you come back for
I don't know I'm just coming to get
whatever I can close
anything I can Savage
[Music]
we all out here it's just
become a disaster or struggle
we don't know what we're gonna have
we came
nobody though
clean this up we just need help
knowing what to do next is a problem
replicated all along 7th Street every
house here almost all completely
destroyed in one of the poorest parts of
the poorest state in America it is now a
question of survival
many consider it a conundrum they're
lucky to have
their neighbors retired grandparents
Lonnie and Melissa Pierce died when a
lorry which had been parked close by
crushed their house I'm gonna miss them
dearly I mean dearly Kate lived opposite
the couple for 18 years this is all that
remains of her home I'm glad they went
together because one couldn't survived
without the other one
this place is grieving the dead and
mourning shattered lives
the average wage in Rolling Fork is less
than half the national average people
who had little now have nothing maybe we
can get some industry to come in and
give people some jobs and we they could
have a better way of life you know
because everybody wants to at least try
to live the American life you know that
American Dream
the plight of the Seventh Street
residence is mirrored across this town
people whose daily struggle is often
ignored hoping in their worst moment
that this and they will not be forgotten
Martha Kellner Sky News Rolling Fork
Mississippi